[Music]
this is an interesting episode that i
would like your um
your opinion on stormy as
of sciency things science-y thing
science-y things science cyancy stuff
um a matter of time
with a black hole
i i know a little bit about
times gaussian science i like i like
scientific theories and things but i
don't get into the minutia so i don't
understand the math i don't understand
the detail and i'll say that straight
off the back
i watched this episode where obviously
um there's there was a new black hole
um on a planet they were exploring that
black hole there was then distorting
time so it looked like on the video
thing that on the video feed that they
were frozen or
talking slowly or whatever they were all
talking like james t cook
yeah
and then
the obviously this
yeah the um the black hole that was then
plugged into the stargate somehow was
powering it so that it didn't shut down
after 38 minutes so that was interesting
that we got to see a bit more mechanics
of the stargate i thought that was
interesting
how about a limit of 38 minutes because
of power that comes back another episode
but from a
science cyancy point of view the time
dilation and things never seemed quite
right to me
and definitely the way that it was
projecting through
the gate
um not the fact that it did but the fact
that the way it worked never quite
seemed right to me
do you guys think okay
[Music]
okay so
as a story
it worked kind of well right
we would have to um
okay so
the effects of gravity is based on
mass and distance let's say you have two
objects
the closer they are the more the
attraction is
uh the bigger they are the more
attraction is so when you combine
the the deep the the distance is very
close and the mass is very close and you
can get great gravimetric distortions
now the way the gate works as premised
in the series
is that you're opening a wormhole from
one place to another
and i think i haven't studied this i
haven't read anything about it really
it's
anyway
we have to accept
that the time that these guys are on the
planet the sg team that's on the the
planet that's
being torn apart by a localized black
hole
that that time
that that gravitation
when it gets let's say gravit the
gravity is 1g at the uh star gate worth
with the uh off world next gt is one
let's let's assume it's a one well we
also have to assume that the gravity
also equals one throughout the entire
distance of the wormhole right okay so
when it gets to earth i mean how many
you know
billions of light years millions of
light years
are they away from so we have to say
well gravity
if the if in this wormhole somehow the
um
the
the stargate trans transmits or or
keeps the gravity
going and transmits it along with the
the material objects the mass
and
i i think that's something where the
scientifically they kind of jump the
shark because we've seen you know like
uh
you know
like they will be in like uh
you know bright desert or something and
they'll come through and then it's just
like normal illumination right
the photons
don't cross over but the gravity does
[Music]
to me i mean if there is i mean there's
lots of little schisms and there's lots
of videos on youtube concerning like
the the physics of of of the gravity and
the black hole and you know
um
jack dangling over the black hole with a
cable that's obstructing around him as
he's trying to place the charge or
whatever it was
but for me it was like well how is the
gravity transmitting or translating or
traversing the
the wormhole how's that energy being
transversed i always notice whether if
the gravity was strong enough that it
was distorting time to the degree that
it did in that video but it didn't
like have any other
i would have thought the gravity would
have to be so strong to distort time by
that factor
that wouldn't it cause more harm i mean
it broke a window but it broke a window
like
ages after you know i mean it's like it
was distorted time by days by factor 10
or 20 or something but it broke a window
towards the end
that was pretty cool that that was
because i mean really slowly towards
them like that that was because the
the gate
basically had a lensing effect on it so
the closer you were to the stargate it
was coming out like yeah yeah like we
didn't we didn't feel the effects so you
say we were updated we didn't feel the
effects of time but if you were further
away it would have been like days weeks
months you know yeah yeah that's true
yeah was an immediate thing
going on what you said about uh how
would the gravity transfer
two-way travel between a gate is
possible because we know radio waves
travel to two ways
yeah
so i don't know i i i think gravity is
like the fundamental force of of the
universe
surely that can with it can't be
destroyed
you can't destroy gravity as well as
just
maybe still
okay so gravity comes from ma
essentially
you know
it comes from mass
so if you turn mass into
total if you can totally convert all uh
all mass to energy you no longer have
mass to generate gravity
something like that that's just my
low-level
calculus-based physics understanding of
the of how that works
that don't exist as well which is a
little bit difficult to get two sciency
wines surely
then there's the whole thing about
wormholes do they actually exist have we
ever seen one you know
you know it's just dude we're we're
still struggling with the magnetars you
know
yeah exactly
i do wonder if
matt makes a good point in that it's
supposed to be plugged into the wormhole
that's what i suppose the world was
supposed to so the black hole supposed
to be powering the stargate but wouldn't
have shredded it by that point but but i
suppose that's getting here we're
getting into two anusha
right but if we're going on
i'm not sure the black hole was actually
powering the stargate the way i saw it
it wasn't powering it at all it was
literally the time dilation effect
the gate was open on that side but
because the time dilation effect was so
long
i suppose that's why the gate stayed
open for so long i mean the circuit
it was oh that's a good point that's
good i don't think it's actually power
in the gate i think it literally is just
time dilation just enforced it's being
forced to because well that goes into if
we're talking about time travel
an episode that is actually i think
quite popular within the fandom
in the episode
[Music]
you